the Penguins captain and three times
Stanley Cup champ Sid thanks for joining
us how's morale today it's good it's
good things are finally starting to
settle down a bit here so you know it's
been fun to to celebrate but you know
looking forward to getting home and
relaxing a bit
have you had the cup yet no I get it I
think later on in the summer so it's
always fun to bring it home so I'll I'll
be excited for that but it's nice to
have a little bit of time in between but
what did you do the two previous times
and what do you do differently with the
cup is tomorrow well the previous two
times I just brought it home to the Cole
Harbour and basically try to do as many
things as possible
I had a hockey school last year that I
had so that was that was pretty neat to
show the kids and the staff and everyone
there and I think this year just with
you know how soon the hockey school is
going to be it's not going to work out
that way but just basically try to try
to get as many people as many eyes as
possible to be able to see it and get
pictures with it and just share it with
as many people as I can
what's your favorite story about what
somebody did with the cup that you're
allowed to say on the air I think the
the pool routine has probably been
probably the thing I remember the most
is I remember Mario saying that you know
they'd put the cup in the pool and in
the early 90s when they won and he'd
like to see it go in the pool again and
you know since since oh nine I think
every time we wanted to ended up in
somebody's pool so that's kind of been a
tradition and it's always great to see
it go in there but it is it okay to get
it banged up a little bit you know when
you put it in the pool what's going
straight to the bottom no it's not not
right away
oh that's opposed no it's uh everyone
makes sure they handle look at all they
do I'm not sure if it's it's supposed to
go in there but usually when do the cup
handlers aren't looking you you find
your time and you get in there quick and
then they're there pretty quickly to
take care of it so yeah it's not their
fault but we usually find a way how did
it feel the first time you lifted that
couple on the ice it's a it's a pretty
special feeling I mean that's that's
what you dream of doing and you know for
us when we want two no.9 that was you
know a year that you know probably meant
even more just because we lost the year
before to the same team so when we
played Detroit losing to them you never
know if you're going to get back there
and it will get back there the next year
and to win and a lot of us you know
we're we're pretty young to be able to
win it so just a dream come true and
that's what you play for Sidney Crosby
joining us Dan Patrick show how good a
goalie was your dad oh that's a tough
one I haven't ever seen him play I don't
think he's put on the gear I haven't
seen him put on the gear at all my
entire life I know that did he tell you
story know that he was yeah I oh he sure
did he told me a lot of stories most of
them were the the big saves he made but
yeah just just you know being able to
hear hear his stories I know that he was
drafted by Montreal and you know I grew
up a Montreal fan as a kid so that was
pretty cool to hear some of the stories
that he had and kind of hear about his
experiences and stuff growing up but
yeah I haven't seen him put on the gear
we always asked him to and says he wants
to but it hasn't happened yet wait a
minute when you're younger he doesn't
put on the gear and let you go against
him not on the ice probably playing
street hockey and things like that he
going well he's never been he never been
on the ice and then played goalie
against me so for whatever reason it
just hasn't happened
I go five hole in your dad every day hey
same yeah you got a great politician he
had a big five hole stand-up Holy old
school that's where you got to go did
you ever want to be a bully
oh yeah that's um
and I want to be a goalie you know
pretty early on and he tried to he try
to stop you can want to be a goalie told
me that it's not not fun you just stand
there you're not around the puck very
much and it's true as a kid you're not
you know as a goalie you're not really
that involved everyone's kind of chasing
the pockets going everywhere so he
convinced me not to and yeah it was it
was something I probably liked more you
know as a young kid though definitely
you know with all the gear and things
like that
would the Penguins ever let you play
goalie I don't know there's I think
there was one time I want to say either
early this year last year that you know
we had to call emergency you know
emergency goalie I think one of our
goalies got hurt and I think flower was
sick and I don't know if they could get
someone there in time so we had we had
somebody kind of in the lineup as far as
you know ready to go in as the third but
I told them if anything ever happened
I'd love I'd love to get to nod and be
bill with play one game and I should
also we'll see there's still some time
left if ever came down to it but that
could be the way they'd love to get that
they should let you do that when you you
know ten years from now when you get
ready to retire like you're able to play
at one period
Ingle that'd be pretty cool whoever dies
give me the guy you want to face like
anybody in the history of the game your
goalie and they're coming no penalty
shot what do you want to face Wow
maybe that's ook just because I feel
like he's made so many goalies look bad
and if I could somehow find a way to to
get my pad on it or stop him he seems
like one of the best best shooter guys
that there was so on a breakaway he'd be
pretty good how would you stop you oh I
can't tell you that okay III thought
that it was the off season you know what
I'll wait till you retire and then you
could say this is I want to talk about
that bad yeah did you play another sport
yeah I did I played the
you know when I was younger like hockey
wasn't that you know in the summer
nobody really played a lot of spring
hockey and summer hockey early on it
kind of has I got a little bit older it
started to become a little bit more
popular but I played a lot of baseball
in the summer which was great
so it gave you a rest from hockey and we
got to really we had a pretty decent
baseball team and you know some of the
guys that were we're playing hockey with
in the winter and playing baseball with
in the summer and same with coaches and
things like that so it was pretty pretty
cool to be able to play both sports and
kind of have that that set up being from
a small town look you root for who was
your baseball team in the Nova Scotia uh
the Expos where the were the team
probably I followed the most and
remember they had a great team that year
that I think the year the strike I think
it was 94
yeah I want to say yeah they had a great
time here they could have unbeliev it
made a run but it didn't happen but yeah
basically the Canadian teams I mean the
Expos and the Blue Jays were the two the
two that I followed the most and there
was a pretty big influence of Red Sox
fans being on the East Coast too so yeah
that was you know that was fun to follow
them do you have another nickname I mean
it was the next one and then Sid the Kid
is there any those feel a little bit old
now sore anything that we're graduating
to I haven't heard anything what he got
remakes anyway nothing wrong yeah so I'm
sure in Nashville they called you other
things right yeah there's a few
nicknames I heard there but those yeah
those what if I haven't heard anyone
help me with the szubin thing that you
were really givin him the business and I
thought it would be maybe the other way
around but I mean you weren't going to
town on him like you were an enforcement
was that during the end the net Darren
yeah wait were there other moment yeah I
know no no I wasn't sure I wasn't sure
if you were talking with that or after
one of the games but know that that was
just he had my leg in a pretty bad
position and you know at that point he
didn't have a stick he was trying to he
was trying to I don't know what he's
trying to do to my leg but
we couldn't see that on TV I just saw
you banging his head onto the ice there
I didn't know he was doing so Yona no I
felt them grabbing my leg and ankle and
then trying to determine tits like you
know what are you gonna do it wasn't uh
it wasn't as bad as it looked
oh it looked great you know I know it
looked bad but oh look great
it wasn't bad for you it might have been
bad for him but I I thought I thought it
was awesome there hey congrats on the
season and another Stanley Cup
championship there have fun with the
trophy and we appreciate you joining us
okay thanks a lot appreciate it that's
so Sidney Crosby the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience